THURSDAY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER PROOF YOUR VISOR AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S%
PURSUIT BEING MADE IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDED THIS HEARING
BEFORE A MASK AT ALL TIMES
ATTENDEES MUST REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE TO ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS RULES COMMITTEE
HEARING. VIOLATION OF THE RULES
WERE SUBJECTED INDIVIDUALS
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT HERE FLORA
GIPSON HERE LEE HERE
MAIENSCHEIN HERE MATHIS RAMOS
YOUR RUBIO HERE PEOPLE WHO ARE
HERE. EVER HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA IS ALMOST ALL OF THE
SENATE GENDER MOVERS TO GIPSON
SECOND OF IMMERSIVE REAL FOOD
ONE OF MR CERTAINLY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY HI- HIGH
CUNNINGHAM. SENATE SENATE HI
FLORA GIPSON FIVE GIPSON HIGHLY
LEE AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE RAMOS
RAMOS I RUBIO RUBIO HIVE YOU
PUT WHAT YOU COULD WELL I WEBER.
WITH THE ADDITION VOTE OF THE
MOTIONS PASSED I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING TO GET
THIS DONE THIS MORNING THANK
YOU EACH ONE. AND YOU MAY LEAVE
ALL REMAIN HERE FOR A
COLLEAGUES TO ARRIVE.
THIS
RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.
OKAY RIGHT RIGHT.